Jocko.
Oh,
I was wondering what your advice is for disagreeing up the chain of command.
Obviously this needs to be done with some tact I eat in private,
not in front of others,
but in those private conversations.
How should one respectfully disagree?
Again,
s again,
similar question.
A better technique than disagreeing is just to ask questions.
You know,
boss,
Hey,
I want to make sure I get this right.
Can you explain it to me again?
Can you,
can you watch me do it right?
So your boss actually sees what the problem is.
That way you're,
you're not being authentic.
Gee,
Hey boss,
can you explain why you chose this course of action?
I really want to learn from,
from what you do,
what you,
the way you do it.
I again,
does that sound like a kiss ass?
Yes.
Cause I'm exaggerating.
You know what I mean?
He boss,
you're still incredibly smart.
No,
I'm not talking about that because bosses don't like ask us issues or at least
good bosses.
Good bosses don't actually even good bosses.
They might keep their kiss asses around,
but they don't respect him.
So you don't gain influence by being a kiss ass.
It's not a good situation.
So I'm not talking about kissing ass,
but you know,
hey boss,
I'm really want to understand this and make sure I understand it.
Can you,
can you explain to me why this is the best way to make this,
to do this versus the other way?
You know,
that's the kind of question that's not kissing ass.
That's actually,
you know what it is actually legitimately wanting to know.
Like I legitimately want to know,
maybe you wait,
what if we,
instead of assuming that we know better than our boss,
what if we assume that my boss knows better than me?
Let's make that assumption.
And if you communicate with that assumption,
then you're probably going to communicate in a much better way than
communicating with the assumption that my boss is an idiot and I know better
than him.
Yeah.
Which is not a good way to communicate.
Funny when you,
now that you kind of said that about the kiss ass guy,
cause that comes up a lot because I don't want to be kissed ass and yeah,
you don't the kiss ass guys the same thing as being friends zoned.
You know what friends owned mean?
Yeah I do.
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
So like the girl,
right?
Typically it's the guy who gets friend zoned.
Right?
Cause he's like too nice.
He's too nice.
He's too whatever.
He'll,
it's,
he's like,
he's essentially a,
you're like a brother to me.
Yes ma'am.
That's what he is.
So of course the girl is going to keep them around for all this like good
feelings superficially by the way you mentioned launch,
all of that stuff,
all the superficial stuff.
He's not going to get anywhere of legitimacy with her actual decision makings if
you translate that into the,
you know,
work environmental,
whatever.
Well yeah the boss,
I mean a certain kind of bosses,
like a certain girls going to keep a guy around for that reason.
Certain boss is going to be like,
y'all keep him around.
I feel a little bit bad even firing the guy like that a little bit cause he's
just so nice to me and gives me all these compliments and even in,
in a,
in a weird way,
I think the kiss ass guy kind of knows that too.
You know?
Like why would he ever fire me even though he's not that good at his job or
whatever.
Right.
Um,
because you know,
he can fire me guns just too nice to him.
You know,
there's that feeling is floating around is what I'm saying.
But it's the same deal.
Right?
Like it's too many compliments.
Too much of a yes man.
I'll keep you around for very superficial reasons,
but that's it.
You don't get past.
Yeah,
that's,
and that's not a good no place to be in.
No,
it's not sir.
That's why I'm not saying kiss ass and,
and the way I just explained that of,
of actually assuming that your boss knows more than you is,
is a good way to approach the situation as opposed to approaching the situation.
Like you know more than your boss.
Why act like that the outcome isn't going to be inferior.
The outcome is inferior.
The outcome of acting like your boss or assuming that your boss knows more than
you know the outcome is you treat them with respect.
Because the other way you could try and treat them with respect,
respect,
but inadvertently you sound like,
you know,
some people I just,
we,
we talk about normal face,
right?
Some people they cannot even ask a question
in an in a respectful way,
right?
They can't even,
what was I saying over here?
They can't even say,
you know,
hey boss,
can you explain this to me cause I really want a hundred.
I can't even say that.
You know,
hey boss,
can you explain this to me because this doesn't make any sense.
You know what I mean?
Like they can't even,
they can't even ask a question in a respectful way.
Yeah.
That's a skill you should master as a leader and as a follower,
as a leader and as a follower.
How to ask questions in a respectful way.
Lafe pointed this out.
Life pointed out.
We were talking about the fact of,
of,
I would say [inaudible] is a story.
He's told a bunch of times of going through the kill house and he's in the back
of the train and you shouldn't be in the back of the train.
You should be somewhere where you can lead everyone.
Cause when you're in the back of the train,
you don't know what's happened in the front of the train of assaulters.
A big group of people moving through kill house and I didn't.
And he goes,
you know,
Jocko didn't say,
Hey,
stop doing that and do it this other way.
He's like,
he asked me questions and he's like,
they were real questions.
I wasn't like,
Hey Lafe why the hell are you in the back of the train?
Is that a respectful question?
No,
it's not a respectful question,
but it's like,
hey leaf w what are you doing in the back of the train?
This is a respectful question.
I,
I'm actually assuming that maybe life who doesn't have the experience that I
have,
who's my subordinate as a platoon commander.
To me,
that big task unit commander,
my assumption is not that I know more than him.
My assumption is that he's got a reason for that.
My assumption is that he knows more than me.
Yeah.
Which,
well,
this is one of the,
one of Jordan Peterson's 12 rules for life.
It's like a,
I think it's assumed the person that you're talking to knows more than you.
What I'm saying is the same thing up and down the chain of command.
You assume that your boss or your subordinate,
no.
Something that you don't know and if you can,
if you can ask questions in that way,
instead of asking questions,
boss,
what are we doing this for?
Yeah.
Or life.
Why are you doing that?
Why are you in the back of the train?
That's stupid.
No,
it's like,
hey life,
why are you in the back of the train?
What do you,
what is,
what is your purpose of being back there?
I genuinely,
genuinely want to know,
and this isn't like,
I'm not even saying I'm acting like that.
I truly,
genuinely want to know what the dealers,
yeah,
so make the assumption up and down the chain of command that your boss,
your subordinate,
knows more than you,
and then ask good questions with true,
genuine curiosity that you want to know the answers to.
It's a good way to go about it.